les états unis où plus de mille
personnes ont encore succombé au cours
d'un virus ces dernières 24 heures la
barre symbolique des cent mille décès a
été franchie hier c'est le pays le plus
endeuillé au monde pourtant qu'il ya
encore quelques mois donald trump
affirmant que la situation était sous
contrôle
retour en images sur l'évolution du
discours du président américain depuis
le début de la crise
[Musique]
e
le virus n'aura aucune chance contre
nous aucune nation n'est mieux préparés
ou plus résistante que les états unis
nous avons la meilleure économie les
soins de santé les plus avancées et les
médecins scientifiques et chercheurs les
plus talentueux du monde messieurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas du tout raciste non pas du
tout ça vient de chine
voilà pourquoi ça vient de chine je veux
être précis
[Musique]
et
et puis je vois que le désinfectant la
somme en une minute
est ce qu'il ya un moyen de faire
quelque chose comme ça avec une
injection à l'intérieur ou presque comme
un nettoyage
[Musique]